JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I'm John McCutchan.
I'm a software engineer on
the Dart virtual machine.
And later on today,
I'll give a talk
on the Dart
programming language.
But for now, I
want to talk to you
all about creating
games in HTML5.
This talk is going to
kind of cover everything,
from the basic tech stack and
some frameworks to some kind
interesting, cutting
edge ideas of how
to make HTML5 games
really compelling.
So let's get started.
So there's a lot of success
stories out there right now.
There's a 3D graphics and
physics engine designed
for making HTML5 games produced
by the Turbulenz company.
They make some really high tech
stuff, a very advanced physics
engine and rendering engine.
And it's entirely open source
so that you can go and grab
it and start developing
with it for free.
Nickelodeon has made
hundreds of HTML5 games
and has a lot of
active users on them.
And recently, as part of
a push for HTML5 games,
the people behind "Cut the
Rope" ported it to HTML5,
and they have a really good
kind of post mortem of what
it took to go from Objective-C,
an iPhone application,
to a native HTML5 game.
And they seem to have had
a very positive experience.
So there's a few
frameworks out there.
I've already
mentioned Turbulenz.
But an interesting
one is Impact.JS,
which allows you to develop an
application once that will run
on Android phones, iPhone,
in browsers, everywhere.
And Impact is primarily used
for 2D graphics development.
So these are some
frameworks that you
might want to pick up instead
of starting from scratch.
So I want to talk
about the tech stack.
This talk is kind
of taking anyone
who doesn't know anything
about HTML5 game development
and bootstrapping you up.
So it's really
important to understand
what's available to
you as a developer.
So this is at a
really high level.
Along the top, we have
different languages
that you can access the HTML5
APIs through, JavaScript, Dart.
And on the right is PNaCl, and
I'll talk a little bit more
about that later on.
But HTML5, from a game
developer's perspective,
consists mostly of
Canvas, WebGL, WebAudio,
and some miscellaneous APIs,
which I'll cover momentarily.
So the canvas that's
available in HTML5
is a 2D pixel storage buffer.
And this has 32 bits
per pixel of resolution.
So this is a byte for red,
green, blue, and alpha.
You can control how
large of a buffer
you use to render into with
the width and the height
properties.
This is not how big it's
displayed on the page.
You can scale up your
canvas to be full screen
or as small as you want, but
you have to be aware of that
when you're kind of creating
the resolution of the surface
that your game will
be rendered upon.
Canvas offers two
ways of interacting
with the pixel data.
You can issue 2-D vector
graphics operations and render
in something like
SVG, PostScript,
PDF rendering model.
This allows you to have
really, really crisp looking
graphics and shapes because
everything's vectorized,
and regardless of how much
zoom you have applied,
the lines are always
anti-aliased nicely.
For more of a
direct approach, you
can actually get at the pixel
data stored in the canvas.
You can read it
with getImageData,
and this returns a
typed array back to you.
And then you can actually
alter the pixel color values
directly.
And then when you're done,
you can putImageData,
and that will update
the data in the canvas
element that's being displayed.
So I want to take
a quick second here
to show you a canvas-based game.
This has actually been
written in Impact.JS.
Sorry about the screen
resolution size.
We're a little cramped here.
So you get the idea
of the kind of game
that you can make just
purely canvas based.
And this is built
using Impact.JS,
which has a level editor and a
lot of other content creation
utilities.
So you can get yourself
to a game of this caliber
relatively quickly.
Built on top of Canvas is WebGL.
WebGL actually sits on
top of a canvas element,
and instead of getting the
canvas rendering context,
you get a WebGL
rendering context.
Right now, WebGL 1.0 is
available in most browsers.
It's just recently
become available in IE11.
Before that, there was no
WebGL available in any Internet
Explorer.
So WebGL 1.0 kind of
lines up with OpenGL ES
2.0, which is kind of old.
It's from 2007.
So that's almost
seven years old.
It's starting to feel
a little out of date,
but it's actually
almost as capable
in terms of the
graphics that you
can express as PlayStation
3 or an Xbox 360.
So despite it being
seven years old,
you can still make
really compelling
3D content with WebGL 1.0.
What's currently in development,
though, is WebGL 2.0.
And this is mirroring OpenGL
ES 3.0, the specification
that was just announced
this past summer.
So next year, when WebGL 2.0
becomes a little bit more
stable and people can start
experimenting with it,
you're going to get a lot
of really cool features,
and the graphics API is
going to be very current.
I mean, cell phones are
just now getting access
to OpenGL ES 3.0 content.
So you can see how close the
HTML5 platform is aligning
itself with native
software development.
Of course, the big
question with WebGL
is, what about mobile devices.
One, can you use WebGL
on an Android device?
And the answer is, in
Chrome 30 for Android,
WebGL will be enabled by
default for many devices.
Today, though, you can go
in, and you can actually
enable an experimental
flag in Chrome on Android
and get access to a WebGL
rendering context on the phone.
So you can start
development today
knowing that going
forward in time,
WebGL will become more
pervasive on mobile platforms.
So there's also WebAudio, and
this is how you play sounds.
WebAudio is a really powerful
audio playback engine.
It has extremely low latency.
You can actually schedule clips.
And when you're
making a video game,
it's really important that when
the bullet graphically hits
the wall, that the sound effect
plays at that exact instant.
If they're out of sync, the
user experience is not the same.
It's not as immersive
as it should be.
But with WebAudio, you can
actually schedule clips.
So in your game
logic, you know when
the bullet is going
to hit the wall,
or when the player--
when Mario's going
to smash through the bricks.
You can predict
forward in time when
that's going to
occur and schedule
the sound effect so
it happened then.
So WebAudio is perfect
for creating video games.
It also has some
really cool things
like filters and 3D
positional effects.
So you can actually, as the
player moves through the world,
you can move the kind of
virtual microphone that
is hearing sounds, playing
through your speakers,
with the player, so that when
an enemy is behind the player,
they'll actually
hear it if they have
a sophisticated enough stereo.
And of course, it supports
all the standard file formats.
Some miscellaneous APIs
that are important for games
are the fullscreen API, and this
allows you to take any element
and actually have it
own the entire screen,
and pointer lock.
And pointer lock is really
important for first person
shooters.
And I've actually written an
article on how to implement
"Quake" or "Doom"-style keyboard
and mouse input in an HTML5
game using pointer lock.
Something that will become more
and more important as games
on the web become more
sophisticated is web workers.
And web workers
will actually allow
you to farm off work that
is computationally expensive
and move it onto a
separate thread that
doesn't block the
render process.
By doing this, it
will allow your game
to continue to have 60 frames
per second while doing work
that might computationally
take a long time in an isolated
worker, away from
your render thread.
So I said we'd talk a
little bit about PNaCL.
And PNaCL is Portable
Native Client.
So Native Client gives
sandbox native code execution.
So Native Client consists of a C
and C++ compiler and the Native
Client SDK, which gives
you standard Unix APIs.
So if you have an application
already written in C
that runs on Mac OS or Linux,
porting to Native Client
is trivial.
All of the standard APIs that
you expect a Unix operating
system to present to you,
they're available, they run.
And you can actually
have POSIX threads.
You can have a shared-memory
concurrent multi-threaded
execution environment,
all running
inside of the browser
safely and securely.
You get things like standard
File I/O, BSD sockets.
You can open up a TCP connection
and connect out to a server
or have someone connect to you.
Alongside of the C compiler
and the Native Client SDK,
there is the Pepper Plugin API.
And this actually exposes all
of the HTML5 features that
I've just talked about,
like WebGL and Canvas,
and actually gives you a C++
interface to those features,
so you can actually leverage
all of these things that are
available to HTML5 in C. And
of course, with Native Client,
you get really close to
native CPU performance.
And I've got a demo later on
showing how you can actually
bridge these two worlds and
write a game that is partially
written in JavaScript
and partially written
in Native Client and get some
really exciting stuff out
of it.
So for those of
you who don't know,
I come from the games industry.
I used to work for
PlayStation for many years.
And probably the thing
that game developers
are obsessed the most
with is performance.
And you want 60
frames per second.
You want to have your
game run really smooth.
So it's important that,
coming to the HTML5 platform,
game developers understand where
some of the common performance
traps are.
So JavaScript lets you be really
fast and loose with types.
Everything in
JavaScript is an object,
and you can manipulate
it anytime you want.
You can add a new property
to an object in JavaScript.
You can remove a property.
You can do whatever you want.
But your JavaScript
execution engine,
like V8 or SpiderMonkey,
they really, really
want you to be as
static as possible.
So in the VM world,
we call this modifying
the shape of an object, meaning
whenever you add or remove
a property, you're
changing the way
this object looks in terms
of the memory layout.
And JavaScript engines
want a static shape.
So if you see this
code here on the wall,
we have a Player class.
And inside there, we
add the x property,
the y property, health property.
And then your code
instantiates the Player class.
And then at some point later on,
indicated by this arrow here,
some piece of code adds the
items array to the player.
The player now can hold
items in its inventory.
But the moment that happens,
the runtime undoes all
of the code optimization that
has occurred, and your game
starts running slowly
for a little while.
It can recover.
But if you do this enough, the
JavaScript execution engine
will just throw up its hands
and say, objects of this class
change so frequently, I
can't optimize for them.
And at that point, the
performance of your application
is going to suffer greatly.
Similarly, all method
dispatch in JavaScript
is done at run-time.
But again, your
JavaScript engine
wants you to be as
strict as possible
to get the most performance.
So inside the function
tickObject on the slide,
you can see that a variable
called obj is passed in,
and then the tick
method is invoked in it.
And since JavaScript
doctyped, so long
as obj can respond to tick,
this code will execute.
It's safe.
It's great.
But if there's many
different types
of objects being seen
at that call site
where the arrow is, the
JavaScript engine again
will say, OK, well, first
it was just one type.
Now it's a few types,
and I'm OK with that.
But then after
four or five types,
it's just going to give up
because the state of the world
is so dynamic that the
gains from optimizing
are thrown away every
time you deoptimize.
A final performance trap
that you should really
be aware of with HTML5 games is
the cost of garbage collection.
Every single time
your game allocates
memory-- some examples
are at the red arrow,
calling new on a class, using
array literals or an object map
literal.
There are memory allocations.
Every single one of
these brings your game
closer and closer and
closer to a pause.
And when it's paused,
nothing is happening.
You could be in the
middle of updating
the player's state in the world.
Everything is frozen.
A couple milliseconds tick by,
and you've dropped a frame,
and the experience
isn't that great.
There's also some less obvious
locations of memory allocation.
If you have unoptimized
code or code
that you triggered a
deoptimization, which we just
talked about, just
doing simple arithmetic,
like adding numbers together or
multiplying numbers together,
every single one of those
operations allocates memory.
And by doing so,
you're moving yourself
closer to this
GC, which is going
to cause a hiccup in your game.
So I want to talk a
little bit about tools.
There's a CPU profiler
and a memory profiler
built into Chrome.
And I'm not going to talk about
the memory profiler today.
But I will spend some time
talking about different ways
to profile CPU
usage in your game.
Again, game development is
often about squeezing out
the last little
bit of performance,
so knowing the tools
that are available to you
can really help you
make a compelling game.
So there are two primary
ways of profiling CPU usage.
The first is sampling, and
the second is structural.
So sampling is what happens when
you go into Chrome DevTools,
and you go to
Profiling, and you say,
collect a JavaScript
CPU profile.
That's doing sampling profiling.
And I'm going to go into
a little bit of detail
about what exactly that is.
Whereas structural profiling
is a bit harder to get to,
but it can sometimes provide
you with much more insightful
information, and we'll see why.
So sampling CPU
profilers, what they
do is at a fixed frequency,
say once a millisecond,
they pause your program.
Instantaneously, they stop
the program's execution.
They unwind the call stack.
They figure out
where your code is.
They record that, and
then your application
resumes execution again.
So let's look at a
little example here.
So let's say that the code is
executing inside bar, right?
So the sample tick comes in
and pauses your application.
So bar was called
by foo, and foo
was called by your main program.
So the call stack you
can see on the right.
This is what's collected
by a sampling profiler.
So at this instant in time, this
is what your program was up to.
But there's a big
assumption baked into this,
is that that sample, that
instantaneous moment of looking
at what your program is doing,
is actually representative
of what your program is
doing between the samples.
So if we take a sample, and
then a millisecond goes by,
and the profiler takes another
sample, and so on and so on,
we have now four sample of
what your program is doing.
But what we don't have
is what your program
was doing between those samples.
I mean a millisecond is
an eternity for a CPU.
You could be doing a lot
of things in a millisecond.
And so this is kind of what
sampling profilers miss out on.
They don't know what you're
doing between those sample
ticks.
So a way to make sample-based
profiling more useful and more
valuable to you as a
developer is to let it
run for a long period of
time, because by letting
it run for a long
period of time,
you get this coarse average
of what your game has
been doing across
many, many frames.
Of course, this doesn't
help you diagnose spikes.
But it does give you a
very accurate picture
of what's going on
in a broader sense.
So when samples are processed
after the sampling is done,
there are two
pieces of data that
are extracted from each sample.
So the first piece of
data is the percentage
of samples where the
function was a leaf.
That's like the top
of the call stack.
It's the thing that's
executing right then.
The second piece of
data is the percentage
of samples where the function
was just present in the call
stack.
So you can see here that the
first type, exclusive time,
is blue, bar, because it's
at the top of the call stack.
Underneath that is foo,
which is inclusive.
So foo was in the call stack,
but it wasn't actually running
at the moment of the sample.
It's not actually
doing any work.
It's just waiting
for bar to return,
and then it will continue
on with its execution.
So these are the two pieces
of data that you get out
of a sampling-based profiler,
just the percentage of samples
that you were at the top or
the percentage of samples
where you were somewhere
in the call stack.
Let's contrast
sampling profilers
with structural profilers.
So in structural CPU
profilers, functions
are instrumented to record
their entry and exit times.
So if we look at this,
we have this buffer here.
So foo gets called
by your main program.
When we enter foo, we record the
timestamp that foo was entered.
Then we enter bar, and
we record that timestamp.
Then we exit bar, and
now we're back in foo,
and we record the timestamp.
And then we exit foo, and
then we record the timestamp.
So if you call foo, foo
calls bar, bar returns,
this is the data
that you collect
in a structural profiler.
So after this data
has been processed,
there are three data
points per function.
You get the actual
amount of time.
Like the sampling profiler
gives you the number of samples,
the number of times on that
one millisecond interval
that you were running.
Whereas structural
will actually give you
exact timing information.
The inclusive time, how
much time, including time
spent in your children,
were you executing,
and then the
exclusive time, which
is how much time
were you executing
at the top of the call stack.
This is actually how
much time that function
is using on the CPU.
And unlike sampling
profilers, you
can actually get the
exact call count.
So you can know how many
times a function is called,
how much time each one of
those function calls took.
It's a much more detailed,
high resolution amount of data.
But there's a cost
because there's
a lot more involved in
gathering these timestamps
and recording the entry
and exit of every function,
whereas sampling profilers
can just tick in.
They can just go tick,
tick, tick, tick, tick.
It's very fast.
So the question becomes,
which one should you use?
And the answer is both.
You should typically start
with a sampling-based profiler,
and this will give
you a broad overview
of where you should be looking.
And then, kind of like using
break points when you're
debugging your software, you
should go in and structurally
profiler chunks of your code
so that you can figure out
exactly how long the
slow parts are taking
and where in particular--
when, let's say, collision
detection is slow, you want
to figure out exactly why
and where in your
collision detection code
the slowdown occurs.
And that's where the
structural profiling will help.
So just as a summary, in
terms of the contrast,
sampling gives you
approximate time.
You can kind of ballpark
it with sampling.
But structural gives you
the exact amount of time
that your code has
been executing for.
Similarly, structural profiling
gives you the exact call count,
where sampling gives you
a rough approximation.
Every sample that is taken that
your function is executing,
you know it was
running, but you don't
know if it ever returned
or, between two samples,
if it was running
the whole time.
Structural profiling
will tell you this.
The great thing about
sampling profiling
is that the overhead is tiny.
It's really, really small.
You can almost do it for free.
Whereas structural
profiling, the overhead
typically can be large.
And if you insert these
structural markers
throughout your
entire code base,
you can drastically slow
down your program, which
is why I recommend using it
kind of the way you use break
points, where you kind
of, as you're searching
for that needle in the
haystack, you move them around,
and you insert them and
remove them from your code.
So I've already kind of
covered this a little bit,
but sampling profiling in
Chrome is just built in.
You just go to the Profiles
tab in the developer's tool,
and you can access it.
There are different ways
to view the samples.
There's heavy or
the bottom-up view.
And these are functions
by impact on performance.
So these are just the most
expensive, exclusive amount
of time running, they're
going to be at the top.
There's also the tree,
which just starts at main
and lets you kind of fan out and
see the whole flow of execution
as it's occurred.
You can also filter
by selected functions.
So if you know that you're
only interested in functions
in this class, you
can actually kind of
grep through all the profiling
data and just see that.
So to use structural
profiling in Chrome,
it's a little bit
more involved, but I'm
going to walk you
through the process now.
If you open up a new tab, and
you go to chrome://tracing,
you get this internal profiler
that's built to really profile
the guts of Chrome.
But you can access and export
data from JavaScript into this,
and this will give you
the structural profiling
that I've been talking about.
So the big trick here
is that you actually
have to go into your
JavaScript code and instrument
it by inserting console.time and
console.timeEnd function calls.
So inside foo, you
can see that there's
console.time foo,
console.timeEnd foo, similarly
in bar.
The overhead of
these macros is tiny
when Chrome tracing is not on.
So you can, in
some circumstances,
just leave them in without a
noticeable performance impact.
But when Chrome
tracing is on, that's
when they actually
get evaluated,
and the data is
collected, and then
the performance
impact can be larger.
So it's important to understand
that structure profiling can
kind of skew the
performance characteristics
of your program.
So once you've gone and you've
inserted the console.time
and timeEnds
throughout your code,
you then go over
to Chrome tracing
and you start recording.
You go back to your tab,
you interact with it,
you run the game for a while.
Then you go back,
and you press stop.
And then you can inspect
the Chrome tracing timeline.
And how you do that is kind of
beyond the scope of this talk.
But there are many articles,
and I've given talks
in the past that go into much
more detail about how you
can actually inspect
the timeline.
But the most
important thing when
it comes to performance
in your game
is that you should
actually have a budget.
So before you go and
start writing your game,
you should try and divvy up
the 16 milliseconds that you
have for your frame
to various subsystems,
maybe three milliseconds for
AI, five milliseconds to draw,
two milliseconds for
the player movement,
or something like that.
You should know
how much time you
want to devote to each system
before you start development.
And you should track
this over time.
Like I said at the
beginning of the talk,
I work on the Dart
VM, and we have
bots that, after
every single commit
we make, the bots go
out and actually run
a bunch of benchmarks.
And they will tell
you, you increased
the speed of this
benchmark by 2%,
or you decreased the speed
of this chunk of code by 20%.
And this is graphed over time.
So you make a commit.
And you can go in,
and you can actually
confirm that not
only have you not
regressed the
performance of your game,
but that you've increased
it the way you expect to.
And you can see this
continued over time.
So if you really are
serious about performance,
investing in something like this
might seem a bit heavy upfront,
but it really does pay
dividends in the end.
Now I want to talk about
Portable Native Client
Acceleration Modules.
So what if you could have 90%
of your application written
in JavaScript, written
in just the DOM, just JS,
but like 10% of
your application,
where the CPU performance
really matters,
could be written in C and C++?
This is what Native Client
Acceleration Modules gives you.
It allows you to extend
JavaScript or Dart with C++.
So NaCl works like this.
You feed C++ code into
the NaCl compiler.
And the output of this is the
NaCl EXE and a manifest file.
You insert a single
tag inside your HTML
which references that manifest.
And then, boom, your
Native Client application
is actually executing
inside that tag at close
to native speed.
So NaCl gives you a secure
C/C++ runtime for the web.
Existing C and C++ code works.
There are people who have
successfully run C# code under
the NaCl sandbox.
And as discussed, you can
interact with the browser
through the Pepper
API and get access
to 3D graphics and
all of the great stuff
that's available in HTML5.
But it requires that
the entire application
be written in C. That's kind
of the classic NaCl story.
But we can leverage NaCl as
an acceleration framework.
Just kind of how you
leverage your GPU
to draw really fast
3D graphics, you
can leverage NaCl to do
the computation for you
very quickly.
So the questions are, can we
provide the native performance
where it counts?
Because if you look
at most applications,
there's only a few places where
performance really matters.
The rest of it,
it's fast enough.
You'll never slow it down.
But code where you're
executing it in a loop
or doing a lot of
computation, that's
where you want the
native performance.
And that's what Native Client
Acceleration Modules give you.
So at a really high level,
it kind of works like this.
By passing messages via
postMessage between the NaCl
module and the JavaScript world
through your render process,
you can kind of
send work to C++,
have the work execute there.
And then when the
work is done, you'll
get a message back
giving you the result.
So how do you build this?
Well, you take an
existing C++ library,
or you write a new one.
And then you expose--
you put an interface
on top of that library that's
built around message passing.
It's built around the idea of
asynchronous computation, where
you're delivered a bundle
that you're expected
to do some work with, and then
later on, asynchronously, you
reply with the result.
So that requires a bit of a
work queue on the C++ side.
I have some code on
GitHub that makes
this very straightforward to do.
And then the final step is that
you write kind of the mirror
of the C++ message passing
API in JavaScript or Dart,
so that you have an API that's
available to your script that
says, OK, go and do some
work over in native land.
And then when that
native land is done,
call this callback, just
like an onClick or something
like that, when the
work is finished.
So I ported the
Bullet physics engine
to Native Client
Acceleration Modules,
and it took about a day.
It was very straightforward.
So in terms of
consumption of-- let's say
you went and downloaded my
Bullet physics acceleration
module.
You really just have
to add a script tag
to get the interface to it
and then add the embed tag.
The cool thing about Native
Client Acceleration Modules
is that they actually don't
take any space up for rendering.
They're invisible.
They're just kind of like
this background workhorse
that you can call into and have
it do some work and come out.
So it's really as simple as
using something like jQuery.
So some example
applications for it
would be like Bullet
physics, simulating hundreds
of rigid bodies, blazing
fast zip decompression,
video encoding and
processing, image processing,
any-- these are examples of
algorithms where you really
need computational power
that is not always available
in JavaScript.
But by using an
acceleration module,
you can leverage
native performance
where it really matters.
So this is a graph
of how many times
can you send a message to a
Native Client Acceleration
Module and get a reply
within five seconds.
The x-axis is how
large of a message
it is, so starting at 16
bytes and going all the way up
to 16 megs.
So you can see that the drop off
starts around 4K message size.
And 4K is actually
a reasonable amount
of data to transmit
across the wire.
And it continues to go down.
But what's really interesting is
that even at 256K per message,
the round trip is
only a millisecond.
And this is asynchronous,
so your JavaScript
is executing code as this
millisecond ticks across.
So at the beginning
of your frame,
you can go and send
a few messages.
The Native Client Acceleration
Module can do the computation.
And then you'll
get that callback
later on before
your frame is done.
So in terms of throughput,
the opposite shape the graph.
As the message size
gets bigger, you
get more data through this pipe.
And it peaks around 420
megabytes per second
if you're sending about a
one megabyte frame of data.
So Native Client
Acceleration Modules
also allow for multiple
acceleration modules
to be used on the same page.
You're not just limited to one.
You could have many.
I have an example
application where
I have a compressor
and a decompressor.
So I can send something
to the compressor,
get the compressed
data back, send it over
to the decompressor, and
get the same data back
that I had originally.
And this is all
within the same page.
It offers really low
latency and high throughput.
To give you some context
to these numbers,
let's say you wanted to stream
1080p video at 60 hertz.
It's only 240
megabytes per second,
which is 60% of the bandwidth
that you have available.
And if you were to do this,
the latency on these requests
is only eight milliseconds.
So it's very practical.
The throughput and
the latency are well
within acceptable means.
And also, think about physically
simulating 1,000 rigid bodies.
You only need seven
megs of data per frame.
And that's only 1.7%
of the bandwidth.
So you could be doing
video streaming and physics
simulation and still have lots
of bandwidth available to you,
and the latency would
be very reasonable.
So I want to pause
right here and actually
show you a Native Client
Acceleration Module in action.
So here's a stack of
Jenga blocks 20 high.
And I can pick up a block
and interact with it.
Whoosh.
What you're seeing here is
what the simulation time is.
So right now, the simulation
for this entire physics scene
is a couple microseconds.
It's super fast because
it's running in native C.
But the graphics
that you're seeing,
I'm just using three.js.
The Native Client
Acceleration Module
is doing all of the
work, and it's just
sending the transformation
matrices back across the wire.
So we could do 400 random
cubes, 400 random cylinders,
just some random shapes.
It doesn't matter.
It's extremely fast because
it's actually running C code
and just transmitting the
transformation matrices back
every frame.
So let's look at the performance
of the NaCl Acceleration
Module versus machine translated
JavaScript, like [INAUDIBLE],
asm.js, something like that.
So what we're seeing
here, the y-axis
is the microseconds
to compute the frame.
The blue line is the NaCl
acceleration module time.
And the red line is the
JavaScript execution time.
You might be wondering,
where is the blue line?
It's that fast that it's
so low on that graph.
So let's zoom in.
Well, actually, before we do
that, it's important to note,
look at how spiky the
JavaScript execution is.
It's really all over the place.
It's very important
with a game that you
have consistent
performance every frame.
You want it to be the same.
You want to see a
flat line there.
But you have these
bizarre spikes.
Probably deoptimizations
have occurred,
and then the engine
recovers, and then
another deoptimization occurs.
So if we zoom in, look at
how smooth and flat and also
how low the NaCl
acceleration module
computation time is
versus JavaScript.
Now what about compressing?
Let's say you wanted
to use the gzip
algorithm to do
some compression.
Again, red is
JavaScript, and blue
is NaCl Acceleration Module.
You can see the performance
difference is huge.
And again, the
performance of NaCl code
is very stable, which
is always attractive.
Look at how bumpy that is.
Similarly, with decompression
timing, fewer data points here,
but the same story holds.
Really inconsistent JavaScript
execution performance,
very stable native performance.
And you can pass the
data back and forth
between these two
worlds asynchronously
without interrupting your
JavaScript execution.
So NaCl Acceleration
Modules are at least
an order of magnitude
faster than machine
translated JavaScript
code, and they
offer consistent performance.
These are both very attractive
qualities to game developers.
So you might have some
concerns, like NaCl
is only available
in Chrome, right?
So if you want to make an
application built around this,
well, maybe you're
restricted to just Chrome.
But I know I've been
kind of demonstrating
how much better
Native Client performs
than machine
translated JavaScript.
But at least you can have a
polyfill where your application
will run in browsers that
don't support Native Client.
Not at the great performance
that you've seen,
but they still run.
Also, applications that
require many back and forth
messages with a lot of
chatter back and forth,
like, NaCl can't make
progress without hearing
back from JavaScript
and vice versa,
this is not good for Native
Client Acceleration Modules.
You really want
something where you
can pass some work across
and then continue on.
But if you need to
kind of synchronously
be chattering back
and forth, you're
not going to see as large
of a performance win.
So it's really ideal
for applications
that are heavily
HTML5-based, with kind
of like 10% native
code execution.
NaCl Acceleration
Modules are going
to allow us to bring new types
of applications to the web.
It's going to allow us
to keep the flexibility
and the productivity of working
in a language like JavaScript,
but keep great performance
that you get from native code
where you really need it.
And the usage, if you
are a web developer that
is consuming an
acceleration module,
it's really straightforward.
You just include a script
tag and an embed tag,
and you're done.
You make the calls, and
it feels like JavaScript.
So this morning, Eric
Bidelman talked to you
all about Polymer, which
is really exciting.
I think Polymer is one of
the most exciting pieces
of technology on the web.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
That's right, woo-er.
So I've been playing
with the idea of,
why not make an entire
3D graphics engine
built out of custom elements?
Why do we have to
write WebGL JavaScript
code to create 3D scenes?
Why can't we just
create a new set
of elements that express
a 3D scene in HTML?
And I just want to
give a quick demo.
It's very early, but
it's kind of cool.
So this is like a
rough sketch of kind
of what it would look like.
Like you would have game-app,
game-player, game-stage,
game-static-mesh.
All of these things
are kind of expressing
these really high
level concepts that
are meaningful to your game,
but it's just in pure HTML.
So let me switch over
to the Dart Editor
and show you a quick demo here.
This is alpha level software.
So please be forgiving
if any glitches occur.
So this is a really kind
of simple scene here.
We have this green
arc is spinning.
We've got this plane
rotating and the ground.
This is expressed
entirely in HTML.
The only bit of code, and
I'll show you in a moment,
is just to animate
the properties.
But let me show you what you
could do in a world like this.
So if we were to open
up Chrome DevTools
and go over to the Elements
pane, we can expand,
and we can say, OK, so
here's our scene tag.
And then we have an
axis-aligned bounding box.
There's that arc
with the green color,
and there's its start and
end angle as it's rotating.
It's updating right
in the Elements pane.
But let's just go
down here and say,
what if we just edited
the HTML and did this?
There.
We just added a yellow
3D sphere to the scene
just by editing HTML.
We can go in and maybe
change the radius to be five.
And there, it's shrunk.
So imagine where you could
create a 3D graphics world
expressed entirely in
HTML with custom elements.
This to me is an example
of how powerful Polymer is.
A lot of the way people
talk about Polymer
right now is kind of
encapsulating a bunch of divs.
But you can actually
take Polymer
to a totally different
level and use
it to create really complicated
applications with tags
that kind of are meaningless
in a strictly HTML5 world.
As a final little
demo here, I'll
show you a simple
Minecraft-like world.
Again, it's all just
HTML at this point.
So the tags here are just
transform tags and draw
this mesh and use this texture.
You can write a
WebGL application
without writing any code.
You just have a texture tag,
and you give it a source,
just like an image
tag, and it's going
to go and fetch that and
upload it into a WebGL texture
for you.
So that's an interesting
use of Polymer I think.
So hopefully, people
will start experimenting
with Polymer in this way.
And I hope to have
more impressive demos
as things mature.
So I left PlayStation and I
joined Google because I really
believe strongly that
the web and HTML5
games are the future of gaming.
The technology that's
available inside browsers
is so powerful today.
It's kind of
amazing that we take
for granted that
within a web browser,
you have the same
capabilities that you have
within a PlayStation
3 or an Xbox 360.
To me, that's really
exciting because the web
is so dynamic and flexible, and
everything happens so quickly
there, and everyone
has a web browser.
So I personally believe
that HTML5 games are
the future of gaming, and
I hope that you guys all
create really awesome
games going forward.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]